so i know you collect sideshow
collectibles and and
i know you're a collector an emergency
happens
you have you know you have to you have
just your hands you gotta be able to you
know to be able to save what you have in
your collection
what's the one or two things you
absolutely save
in an emergency in an emergency you know
what sideshow gave me a
full-sized uh iron man uh
like one of those jack i mean it's
literally like seven feet tall
and it you know it comes in three pieces
so i i think that's the one thing i'd
have to get
out of there uh i would definitely it
would take me three trips
uh but it's it's massive it is so
freaking big and it scares everybody
when they walk in
uh so yeah that would be the number one
piece does it light up and have
electronics and all that
it has the chest lights up the eyes
light up and the hands light up
so yeah it's it's something else and uh
they were
super nice they gave that to me uh you
know i thought that was awesome
yeah listen i uh riddled with envy uh if
i had the space i would want the darth
vader and carbonite
because i just love that thing and i've
loved it since i was a kid but no space
and it's also a ton of money
it's a double whammy you know you're
always going to get hit and they're
always going to keep coming out with
more stuff and you're like oh i should
have said oh i should have gotten that i
should
and also to space i i basically took
over a large
area uh with just sideshow figures i
think about 90 percent of the collection
came from
from sideshow and i got a couple couple
stragglers that made it in
uh i oh listen man we could talk the
whole time of just about this but i'm
i'm going to run out of time so
um jumping into space jam uh did you
take this true or false did you take
this role solely to get better tickets
for lakers games
nice
i got i got my liquor connect
but it didn't hurt it did not hurt uh i
haven't met lebron yet but i'm hoping
that that's gonna happen sooner than
later
uh you know i miss the red carpet that
happened at magic mountain uh because
i'm out here in san antonio doing
concerts again
so uh you know first chance i get i'm
gonna i'm gonna tell lebron who speed he
was
if he doesn't already know i love
learning about the behind the scenes in
the making of a movie
what do you think might surprise people
to learn about on your end
about making space about making this
space jam
uh i think it was awesome that warner
brothers uh reached out to me personally
after i defended speedy gonzalez when uh
canceled culture came after him and i
stood up for the character and said hey
look there's nothing wrong with speedy
gonzalez he's
he's mexican and he's fast that is not a
crime that is job security
so leave him alone and uh and so when it
came time to record they were
very very good about hey gabriel we want
to make sure that you're comfortable
with the role that you feel like he's
being portrayed the right way and that
you know if there's any issues or
questions
please feel free to let us know we want
to make sure we get this right
so i love the fact that they took the
time to do that
they were very very supportive and even
when it came down to the wire
it was like how do you think you should
sound they asked me
what i think he should sound like and
i'm like well i think you should sound
like speedy gonzalez
and they're like you don't want to lend
your regular speaking voice to the part
maybe make him sound a little bit more
modern i said no i says i don't want
people to think of me when they see
speedy gonzalez i want them to think of
speedy gonzales the original
voice and they said you don't think that
voice is too stereotypical
and i say you don't know my family we're
good trust me
you're okay and so when it came down to
record uh that was the voice i went with
and so i right out the gate they're like
and action and you know boom
i am speedy gonzales
wow that's pretty good and i told him i
said you know what i said don't think
that just because i'm mexican i can only
voice the mexican character
i says i can do the entire movie by
myself if given the opportunity
it says you want marvin the martian oh
my oh my modulator
you want yosemite sam oh i like that
rabbit
you want bugs bunny [ __ ] up jack and
porky pig
you get the picture i say you can fire
all the actors right now i'll do the
whole movie for half
first of all i had no idea you could do
that and that is actually awesome
i know i i have to go already but that
is i was going to curse that is awesome
i'm very impressed listen man i gotta go
i'll tell andy that you said hey and uh
thank you so much and congrats and have
fun on the tour thank you stephen i want
to see more of what you got man but i
get it
we got to get our hustle on yeah dude if
i could flip the camera you'd see a lot
more
it was a pleasure man i look forward to
meeting you soon